Quick announcement up top. I'm now
partnered with Dragon Shield. Follow my
affiliate link in the description to get
a discount on your online sleeve
purchases. And keep an eye out in the
upcoming weeks for an awesome custom
sleeve design that me and my artist
friend are cooking up at the moment.
Now, on to the video. Lauren Ecliped is
here and my patrons have decreed that I
will be reviewing the minus oneus one
counter precon, which is great because
blight curse has been a lot of fun to
dig into and is pretty phenomenal as far
as pre-constructed commander decks go in
my opinion. Not because it's a perfect
deck, and we can work on that part a bit
later, but for a lot of other reasons
we'll be getting into. As usual, I'm
going to start by talking about what the
deck is trying to do. Then I'll be
discussing what I like about it, and
I'll finish up with some ways it can be
improved. To start with, let's talk
about this deck's main commander,
Anti-U. She has a four mana 44 with ward
blight 2, and whenever one or more minus
one counters are put on a creature, draw
a card if you control that creature. If
you don't control it, its controller
loses one life. The first thing I notice
about this is a lack of limiting phrases
in the text box. No one or more
creatures and no once per turn. What
this means is that this has the
potential to be a pretty explosive value
generator, easily drawing five or more
cards per turn with the right setup
present on a four mana 44 commander with
a protective ability on it. That's
pretty good. The downside here is the
specificity. In total, there are an okay
number of cards that put minus one
counters on creatures, but it's not a
particularly generous pool to work with
when you consider that these cards
function in a wide variety of different
ways. Some put minus one counters on all
creatures, rewarding wide boards with
massive card advantage, whereas others
gain minus one counters over time,
pushing a slower, grindier play style.
Plenty of others are one-time use. And a
lot of cards that use minus one counters
are primarily intended to put counters
on opposing creatures and are balanced
with that in mind. Do you put these
counters on your own creatures instead
for a bit of card advantage? All this to
say, Anti-Oool is a powerful commander
within her own synergy sphere, and the
challenge in building her is going to be
navigating a limited card pool to create
a deck that plays to her strengths
without ending up too disjointed.
Looking at this deck's cards that place
minus one counters, there are nine cards
that specifically place minus one
counters on your creatures, another nine
that place minus one counters on any
creature, two that place counters on
each opposing creature, and four cards
that place counters on all creatures.
This array of different minus one
counter cards is accompanied by a number
of different payoff cards, which
likewise operate in a variety of
different ways. Eight of these trigger
when creatures with minus one counters
on them die, with most of these
providing either card advantage or
reanimating the creatures under your
control. Another four cards plus the
commander reward the active place
encounters itself. And the synergies get
much more granular from here, including
amplifier cards like evolution sage,
cards that modify the effect of minus
one counters like Kolrath Knight, and
weird roundabout synergies like Tree of
Predition. Some of the setup and payoff
combinations here are quite good,
especially the ones involving cards that
place minus one counters onto all
creatures. And I expect that piecing
together one of these zingy pairings is
a big way this deck wants to get ahead.
Naturally, this deck has a lot of tools
to slow opposing creature-based game
plans given its focus on minus one
counters. And these creature shrinking
options are joined by five cards that
deal with artifacts, enchantments, or
both. Rounding out the 99 of this deck
are moderate counts of both draw and
ramp, much of which involves minus one
counters in some way. Through some
powerful synergies, I expect this deck
will try to get ahead in explosive
fashion, slow opposing game plans with
interaction, and then gradually wear
down opponents with a mixture of
creature attacks and incremental damage.
So, to start with, what I like about
this deck, this strikes me as quite a
Johnny sort of precon. Because the deck
was drawing from a limited card pool,
the minus one counter synergies take a
variety of different shapes, and the
setups and payoffs within this deck
piece together in some really cool and
sometimes really powerful ways. Just
thinking about anti-ool, the cards that
place minus one counters on all
creatures end up being a shamanic
revelation for you and a rattos charm
for your opponents. Both effects that
can be very impactful depending on the
state of the game. Any proliferate
effects can amplify the effect of
previous encounters, creating further
value and damage at a brisk pace. These
plays can also be doubled down on with
an additional payoff card like Hapatra
or Flourishing defenses, which can
really put you in the driving seat of a
game fast. This deck also has two
different cards that reanimate creatures
that die with minus one counters on
them, both at three mana. And this means
that it's possible to perform some
powerful creature stealing maneuvers
pretty early in the game. All this to
say, this deck can do some powerful
things, and the way it operates seems
like it would make for an exciting play
experience for any players who are
especially interested in the way cards
synergize. Just a minute ago, I talked
about the two cards that reanimate
opposing creatures that die with minus
one counters on them. And one of these
two is actually the alternate commander
for this deck, the Reaper, King No More.
And that's another thing I like about
this deck. It actually feels like it has
an alternate commander. The power level
of the card is nice, basically being a
sidegrade of Necroskitter that trades
some raw power for a bit more utility.
And the deck does have a fair amount of
cards that place minus one counters on
opposing creatures in it. So, this deck
has a better relationship with its alt
commander than most precons do in the
sense that if you really like this card,
you can run it as the commander and
probably have an okay time with it. If
you were doing that long-term, you'd
want to tweak the deck a bit since
anti-ool is pretty pivotal to the deck's
card economy. But, the Reaper is already
much closer to feeling good as a
commander in this deck than most
alternate commanders. And I'll talk a
bit later about some possible ways to
adapt this deck to him. As usual, I play
tested this deck 20 times and kept track
of how the first five turns went in an
Excel doc. Overall, it felt decent.
There weren't many games where the deck
was really popping off super early like
I have when I was testing the World
Shaper precon last year, but most games
the deck was doing some decent stuff and
setting up for some cool plays later in
the game. One neat thing is how varied
the deck felt. There are so many
different ways the various synergy
elements can be pieced together, whether
it be making a value engine, making a
removal engine, having a single
explosive turn, putting together a wide
board, and so on. The commander also
really helps with making the deck feel
good for two reasons. For one, she
offers an easy default minus one counter
payoff, reducing the strain on the deck
to find other payoffs. Secondly, the
fact that she's a powerful draw engine
allows somebody piloting the deck to see
more of it, which is super useful for a
deck whose cards are highly varied in
how they work and what they accomplish.
As a final note about what I like here,
the manabase is fine enough for what
this deck is doing. Upgrade it if you
like, but I'll be leaving it alone in my
tweaks. Getting into what I dislike
about playing this deck, the big thing
is dead cards. I had several play tests
where I kept accumulating cards in hand
that were entirely useless in my current
game state. A lot of these cards are
just a bit more specific in their play
pattern or in the way they synergize
with other cards being a little niche or
hard to fully utilize with current
tools. There is one frequently dead card
that we should get out of the way first
though. Liliana Death Wielder is an
intro deck planaineswalker from Ammonet
and it is truly god awful. It' be barely
playable at four mana and in reality
it's seven mana because it's an intro
deck planaineswalker. I guess this was
added to the deck to be an educational
first cut for new players. Allah, Temple
of the False God. But I don't really
like that an iconic Planaineswalker like
Liliana is reduced to serving that role
here. Anyway, that's our first cut, and
it should be a cut basically regardless
of what you want to do with this deck.
Another thing I dislike about this
deck's current form is its creature
count. This feels like a deck that wants
to be running 35 to 40 creatures based
on the number of cards that care about
creatures, but instead it's running 27.
This adds to the awkwardness when the
deck keeps drawing into enchantments and
sorceries and struggles to get much use
out of something like soul snuffers or
grave venerations that really want more
creatures floating around in the
ecosystem. So, these are the main things
I want to be focused on in my upgrade.
Reducing dead draws and upping the
creature count. Before I get into my
other nine cuts though, I really want to
talk about alternative build paths
because that's another reason I really
like this precon as a product. There are
a lot of little elements that could
easily spark some inspiration and be
expanded outward. A few proliferate
cards help the deck amplify its minus
one counters, and one way to modify this
deck could be to lean harder into that
mechanic and add other cards that can
utilize it, such as Astral Chronicopia
or Twitching Doll. There may not be a
massive pool of minus one counter cards
in the game, but there sure are a lot of
other countering cards that can utilize
some of the same payoffs and support.
Another synergy area this deck gives a
taste of is graveyard synergies. There
are several cards that use graveyards as
well as Archi fender that cares about
discarding. These aren't very well
supported now, but you could introduce
some more eluding effects into the deck
to help with these, and this extra
filtering would also likely help the
deck in general in pursuit of assembling
engines. Finally, you could also adapt
the deck to work better with the reaper
in the command zone. There are several
great cards that put minus one counters
on opposing creatures that you could add
if you don't mind paying a bit, such as
persistent constrictor and spitting
Dilophosaurus. And these paired with a
bit more draw would likely make for a
very different but still functional play
style. This would also likely work well
paired with a more graveyard heavy or
proliferate heavy approach as well. You
can do a bit of mixing and matching
among these. For my upgrade, I'm
choosing to go for a more streamlined
approach that eliminates some potential
dead weight and shores up some weak
spots while increasing the creature
count and improving tools for
incremental minus one counters. Let's
start with cuts. Archi of Ifir is
getting cut because this deck has five
other cards to discard and three of
those are cycling lands. This was one of
my first observations after plugging
this deck into architect. I saw an
archbe of IFneer. I dropped fo discard
into the search box and boom, that's an
easy cut unless you're feeling highly
motivated to get more self-discard into
this bad boy. I'm also cutting puka
covenant and persist due to this deck's
lack of graveyard enabling. The former
requires your creatures dying and stuff
in your graveyard to be gotten back,
which is too niche a set of requirements
for the current form of this deck.
Persist will be useful a bit more often,
but its ceiling is also much lower, so
it doesn't excite me either. I am
keeping the rest of the graveyard
synergies around though as they have a
lot more utility than these two.
Speaking of persist puppeteer click.
This card looks like it synergizes with
this deck, but in practice you'll
probably be struggling not to turn off
its keyword more often than you'll be
enjoying that extra anti-ool trigger.
I'm also cutting Grim Poet. This one is
a bit painful as it's a funky card with
some neat possibilities here, but seven
is such a large amount of mana to pay
for something with no guarantee of it
doing much. From here, the final four
cuts are non-creature filler, which will
be getting replaced with creatures and
other options better suited to this
deck. Harmonize and hoarders Greed are
getting cut for alternate draw,
Commander Sphere for an alternate mana
rock, and Cathartic Py for a better
removal spell. I will say the fact that
I'm spending four of my 10 swaps
targeting perfectly passable filler
speaks well to this deck's card quality.
There's just not many truly
objectionable cards here. Now for the
additions. I'm starting here with four
lowcost creatures with blight abilities
from the lurin eclipse to main set.
Donhand dissident, gristle glutton,
scuzzback scoundre, and shadow urchin.
Adding these lowers our curve, ups our
creature count, makes it easier to
trigger the commander on demand. And as
an added bonus, three of these four have
fun alliterative names. You could also
add the haste one if you wanted to, but
I don't see this deck wanting haste on a
single creature all that often. As
replacement creaturebased draw, I'm
adding generous patron, which can
potentially net quite a solid amount of
cards. To replace the mana rock and the
creature removal we cut, I'm adding
staff of completion and grim affliction,
both of which can also proliferate. From
here, I'm also a bit concerned about
this deck's ability to maintain a
healthy life total. It's on the grindier
side. There was already some big life
pay in the deck, and we just added some
more big life pay in the form of staff
of completion. So, the remaining
additions will also perform a
stabilizing role here. Obelisk Spider is
great as a source of incremental damage,
pairing with the commander to pepper
down opponents at a steady pace and
gaining a bit of life in the process.
Pest Infestation boosts the deck's count
of artifact and enjamment destruction
while also gaining life and cementing
the advantages this deck gains from
having a large board. Finally, Elegy
Acolyte gives a nice lifelinking body in
addition to some draw, further smoothing
this deck out in multiple regards. So,
this is our finished version of the deck
with expanded connective tissue and a
creature count of 32, up from 27. I will
say that in my tweaks here, I was very
conservative with my cuts to cards that
pressure opposing life totals. I don't
know that Grave Titan, Lasting Tarfire,
Tree of Predition, or Flourishing
Defenses belong here longterm, but this
is definitely one of the grindier
precons I've seen, and I didn't want to
handicap its ability to win by cutting
perfectly passable pressure options just
because they could be a bit better. I
will also reiterate that money will go
further in upgrading this deck than it
would for a lot of precons. Because the
card pool is so narrow, there are great
cards that use minus one counters that
don't really have budget replacements,
and you'd probably want to eventually
snag those if you're trying to upgrade
this deck to a fully functional bracket
3 form. I will also say that narrow card
pool itself is part of why I like this
precon so much. It'd be easy for this to
end up being a precon that feels a bit
one-trick pony and really constrained in
how you could go about improving it, but
instead the opposite is true. This deck
has a reasonable alternative commander,
multiple possible modification paths
presenting themselves, and it contains
fewer obvious cuts than any other precon
I've reviewed. Part of that comes down
to the cards that are in the deck, but
another big part comes down to the
design of the commander. Anti-ool is a
great enabler for minus one counters
that encourages diving deep into the
mechanic and playing around with
synergy, and that's cool to see. The
overall package works well, and if
you're trying to get somebody into
Commander who is a fan of other card
games or rogike deck builders, this is
going to be a deck with a sweet
aesthetic and a lot of fun synergies for
them to chew on. Thanks for watching,
and thanks to my supporters for helping
me do what I do here. If you want to
join them in supporting me, you can
click the join button or follow a link
to my Patreon down in the description.
You'll be getting access to a back
catalog of bonus videos I made, and you
also may get the chance to have your
deck reviewed by me in one of my
quarterly deck reviews. All right. Bye.